well september is rap star month on this
show apparently last week we told you
all about nicki minaj tonight an
interview with zubi who was a rapper in
the united kingdom
and a very insightful observer of
american politics not at all afraid to
say what he thinks
we sat down with him for a new episode
of tucker carlson today he told us what
he thinks of the covet mandates and the
state of our ruling class is worth
listening to here's part of it
[Music]
when you're in london
um and you're in great britain does
anybody ever say you know i can't
believe what's going on here you have
boris johnson you know smart guy but
can't manage his own life we don't know
how many kids he has you know it's kind
of a disaster personally telling us how
to manage
the intimate details of our lives like
that's wrong does anybody ever say that
millions of people do they do yeah there
are there is there is a resistance i
don't want it to sound like you know
every british person is a sheep who's
just willing to comply with whatever
daddy government says it's not it's not
like that at all um
i think proportionally though
it's it's different and another thing
with the usa and again a lot of
americans take this for granted a huge
advantage of this country beyond its
size and its geographical scale and its
population
is that you have states
right you have 50 different options
within your own country where
you don't like the way things are going
in california you've got 49 other
options you don't like the way things
are here you can you can move without
leaving your whole country whereas with
lots of other countries
if
things aren't going well this is kind of
the position i've found myself in
um like i love the uk i'm a big fan of
the uk it's a it's a wonderful country
in many in many regards
but i was just feeling like man there's
i don't i don't really like the way this
is trending
i have a lot of concerns with this
direction and this response
and with me it's like well
there's nowhere else to go besides
literally
leaving
the whole country which is
bittersweet it's an adventure but i
don't like the
i don't like the fact that i felt like
my hand was forced yeah the things
things were going in such a direction
where i was like man like i don't
i don't know you know again i talk to
people who live in um all the freedom
lovers who are out there in places like
australia right now
it's it's a bad situation i mean you
can't you can't
leave the country
yeah i mean
that in itself it's one thing
you can't leave
it's gone back to becoming to being a
penal colony right so why is that better
than cuba i mean better beaches like
what
this is the thing and you know it's also
been revealed that a lot of people don't
value liberty and freedom perhaps in the
way that we thought that they did or
people claimed to
i think now you're seeing that i've
always had a suspicion that really
people value safety and security or at
least the illusion of it more than they
value freedom and liberty and that's
really proven it's really really proven
to be the case i mean everything that's
going on every government overstep every
bit of authoritarianism or outright
tyranny what's the justification for it
you know for the greater greater good
for your health for your safety that's
always the justification even if they're
clearly clearly going way way way beyond
it's all from people who have no
demonstrated record of success
in the field that they're espousing on i
mean joe biden last week literally got
up there and lectured american parents
on how to raise their kids joe biden
yeah you know whatever his good
qualities
has no right to lecture anyone on how to
raise their children i mean are you
joking he should be ashamed but it's
it's true but it's true across the board
yeah
maybe part of the problem is we have
just inept leaders yeah and the thing is
it's also easy to advocate for things
that don't affect you right this has
been one of the biggest problems all
throughout certainly the i mean it's
always a problem but over the past 18
months especially i mean we've seen this
we've all seen the governors and the
mayors and prime ministers whoever they
are out having having their parties and
going masculist and not socially
distancing and doing this and doing it
violating all their rules going going on
foreign holidays while they're telling
their citizens to stay at home and to
wear a mask and to you know do this and
do that and that i mean it's like animal
farm just that level of outright
hypocrisy yes that's just been rammed in
people's faces
zoomy from the uk that went on for about
an hour interesting you can watch on
tucker carlson by going to foxnation.com
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else